the covet 19 pandemic continues to be
the biggest story throughout the world
and look we try to provide you a
distraction from it but there will be
overlap between covet 19 and the
national football league we're
highlighting at profootballtalk.com all
of the donations made by teams owners
players jimmy and d haslam the browns
owners have kicked in 1.5 million to
help with the broader effort to whether
it's feed people who
aren't getting meals at school who rely
on that whether it's taking care of the
people who are most at risk for a
serious outcome for covet 19 whether
it's just making sure that money is
available to help with the health care
system and the crisis that is looming in
many of our
communities
but the haslams also
pointed out yesterday that we currently
expect to host a full nfl season and
look
currently yes i i just
i don't know chris and i think the nfl
needs to be planning for every possible
scenario and i hope that behind the
curtain somewhere they are identifying
every what if that there is and that
they have a plan for every what if
imaginable up to and including not being
able to play at all in 2020 and i don't
think that's gonna happen i hope it
doesn't happen for a variety of reasons
one of which is if they can't play
football at all in 2020 it will
underscore just how bad this pandemic
becomes because we're talking about
months down the road but the nfl needs
to have a plan in place for every
challenge and every opportunity and one
of the opportunities your former texas
coach matt brown now back at north
carolina he's wondering whether or not
they can have a college football season
chris if there's no college football
season but the nfl finds a way to play
even if the nfl's playing in empty
stadiums all of a sudden maybe you got
nfl games thursday night friday night
saturday night sunday night monday night
filling that void and people are going
to be desperate for sports i mean again
these are some drastic scenarios where
there wouldn't be college football but i
think the nfl is going to be hell-bent
on playing and they're going to find a
way to play there's too much money at
stake
but maybe they will be playing in empty
stadiums maybe they will be playing a
reduced schedule they just need to be
thinking about every possible scenario
and they need to have a plan in place
for however the dominoes fall
yeah i mean i'm with you i'm hoping for
an nfl season certainly i mean a full
nfl season but i don't think we're out
of the woods yet in this conversation i
don't you know i still look at it and go
are we in danger of maybe having a
shortened season or starting training
camp late you know i i still think it's
a flip of a coin of where where we're at
right now and you listen to some you
know most of the medical experts and
people like that so
i wouldn't be shocked to maybe see the
season get shortened by a game or two i
don't know where it goes i'm hoping for
the best but yes the nfl to your point
needs to be ready for all all angles
here and what could happen because we
don't know what's going to happen this
is going to be we're kind of playing it
by ear and just going to see how this
all shakes out and one of the realities
here and i'm going to try to present
this as a politically as possible but we
are detecting i think a looming tension
between those who would say we lock
everything down until the threat
subsides and those who would say the
people who are at risk just stay out of
the mainstream of society and protect
themselves while the rest of us live our
lives and
kick start the economy and go back to
restaurants and go back on planes and
live our lives as we normally would and
i think football is going to be caught
right in the middle of that because you
know a lot of these athletes they don't
care if they get i mean their their
attitude does that
you know i'll be fine um and you can
have it run ramp it through a locker
room everybody could test positive and
nobody can show any symptoms so there's
just a lot of issues chris that are
going to need to to unfold as time goes
by yeah well definitely and then just
you know you're being risky with that
you know that second you know the
thought there with just saying oh we're
going to keep the people who are only
susceptible in that in the house or you
stay away from society you know that
still doesn't mean that young healthy
guys can't get sick and be in big big
trouble
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports